all right in other news now it is back
to school day for thousands of students
at local private and charter schools
today
many will learn in person but it of
course will be a lot different this year
bianca holman is live this morning at
faith lutheran with more on this good
morning bianca
hey good morning alex here at faith
lutheran there are about 2 000 students
and they were able to choose between two
different tracks
learn online of course or learn in
person and when we spoke with school
leaders they say about 90 percent of
their families chose to learn
in person faith has spent a lot of money
on sanitation and social distancing
they've also upgraded technology and are
experimenting with some new tools for
connecting students and teachers
students will be able to be on a
rotating schedule so that no more than
50 percent will be on campus at any
given time
the things would include we're taking
temperatures every morning doing some
health screening we're extending passing
periods we have one-way hallways we're
serving lunch from five different places
we're not gathering for chapel every
week like we normally would
faith lutheran says it will rely on the
southern nevada health district
cdc and governor sislek and that if the
school has to go 100
online they could switch meanwhile
charter schools also start today
most of them had planned in-person
classes but changed plans earlier this
month
as the nevada charter school
administration came out with new
guidelines
of course clark county schools they
begin a week from today and they will be
100 percent virtual reporting live
bianca holman
8 news now